bonjour bonjour
[Applaudissements]
bon déjà je me présente enfin prenez là
que les gens présents chez toujours pas
qu'est ce que je peux les six mais on
est là bon moi je voulais commencer à
parler pour n'a pas vu l'une je crois
que je vais passer les 14 premières
minutes à vous remercier et lui luxe ça
sera largement suffisant
j'ai promis n'est bon eh ben pour
consulat d'emballement si je peux être
pas c'est parce qu'on j'ai guéri
d'appeler une application j'ai gagné une
pétition avec une application
l'application c'est une application qui
est que les gens qui ont des chefs 30
c'est une sorte de boucle pendant la
compétition que j'ai gagné s'appelle
alex pota absente
la dernière série il s'est placé en
jamais bon prêtre
même si je vais plus parler de mon
histoire je vais pas belle vous parler
de quelque chose d'autre
si vous vous pouvez créer votre histoire
tout d'abord je vous rêvez pas vous
remercier d'être venu ici pour écouter
et je remercie aussi l'équipe qui a
organisé les été dit que c'est sympa
d'avoir ainsi remercié les parents
auraient sûrement parce que comme l a
fait
jose quant aux élèves y ont participé
je commençais depuis que j'étais les
versions je vous ai lu par an bon je les
croyais je voulais à faire que c'est lui
mais ont fêté ce travail et c'était des
trucs qui faisait descendre qui
s'illumine et moi j'adorais ça fait
quand même après plus de deux mois que
je suis encore là gît là je commençais à
faire quelque chose comment c'est arrivé
je rêvais d'un jour pour voir avoir cédé
plus de ne pas pouvoir jouer avec les
pats début les français ce que je
croyais mais je croyais que c'était
juste parce qu'il sait c'est qu'il
suffisait juste de leur dire un même
toit fait rançon et ça c'est sgp ça on
s'en faisait en sorte oui je grandissais
et plus je vous disais plusieurs
intrigues
là je faisais les choses je rêvais est
ce un bon jus fonds aux coûts d'une
phrase qu'a dit en filou grave dans
notre société plus que diablo grave et
xavier dolan parce qu'elle a reçu un
prix au festival de cannes 2014
il a dit et l'a résumé toutes les
réussites en une seule phrase et c'était
simple vous avez osé travail et
l'abandonné pas été sera facile
eh bien il faut que copé pour avoir
appuyé il faut commencer par avion moi
je vais défense
je pense arriver à rêver à rabais mais
il fallait que je passe à la deuxième
table
il fallait bien joueuse je me retire
avant je faisais ça je veux ordre je
veux faire ça et plus je me dis c'est
nul ça m'intrigue et que je vais faire
ça et on joue je me suis dit bon alors
là du propos agents d'état et tu le fais
j compenser dit atterré je suis à nation
et j'ai cherché à savoir celle que et
voir comment les manipuler et pepsi les
jours passés et je lui rendais compte
que c'était plus difficile que je le
croyais je n'ai pas à marier parce que
je voyais annonçant un avenir que le
bois est alors j'ai pensé à mon travail
et je compensais avec des trucs à tout
petit peu des billets paris faisait des
places pour tous
le prix du public j pc à faire car elle
avait fait fortune comme elle tue un
enfant de six ans petit versailles
si bizarrement beaucoup ça j'ai vu faire
et qu'on faisait un peu que je vous
montrais à ma mère me disait si bien
j'ai des singes et des faire ça les
sétifiens ont droit et croyez moi la
fierté ou plutôt la réussite ça nous
parle de la fierté dans les yeux des
gens pour le colonel et ses stars en
quelque sorte la réussite et la réussite
c'est aussi être fiable et fabriqué par
exemple un moteur de voiture pour qu'il
parle il faut le remplir de stockage en
jeu c'est quoi
pour vous rêvez vous rêvez vous rêvez
vous et vous le remplissez de calme ne
se retrouvent quelque chose mais pour
qu'il marche ils ont toujours cette
petite flamme qui va tout faire exploser
roux qui va faire un bon ça c'est
lorsque tueuse c'est lorsque tu enfonces
cette fonction sont soit que tu l'a
repéré que tu commences à construire sa
propre personnalité
moi c'est ce que j'ai fait au début du
retour intérieur où elle s'était fiancée
c'est ce qui les commet j'ai conservé
mais aussi il va falloir faire autre
chose cause est ok j'ai rêvé jugé
plausible mais a toujours un petit peu
rires il fallait que je continue la en
conviant la 4e à la 3e étape et c'est là
où il faut travailler mais pas
travailler juste pour survivre 75 ans la
peine
c'est le travail pour sont vives c'est
juste le travailleur qui te réveilles
l'a dit tu veux pas travailler tu
cherches fixe plus en patron
vous étiez de damas je vous répondrai
aux quelque chose que tu fais sans
vouloir le faire voilà ça ça adobuzz
ce soit
tu les passeurs travail font plus peur
soit tu n'es pas motivé pour le verre
est bien le travail ne joue pas assez
travaillé avec u2 et cette cause début
dès que votre objectif que vous avez
devant vous lorsque vous rêvez vous
lorsque vous avez commencé en résine
lorsque vous êtes dit même s'ils sont
tous en asie vous eh ben c'est possible
et vous pouvez faire mais il faut bien
que vous ayez à côté d'elle on peut
gérer à venir faire une seule même si on
lui dit on le voit le jour mais il doit
toujours avoir juste un petit élément
garou qui vous a poussé à faire ceci
pour ma part c'était mes parents et je
les remercie et je crois que c'est grâce
à elle me dit aujourd'hui bien vu mais
avait eu de suivi notre parole
bon pour moi il ya deux ans j'ai
rencontré un ami hockey au collège qui
je crois a changé ma vie
mais moi aussi je lui ai changé locales
et depuis nous reprendrons ensemble on
fait tout ensemble
c'est depuis mon meilleur ami parce que
tout simplement à la belle nation et sa
beauté avec des cerveaux qui ont la même
passion que voue certains postes mais de
bon goût mais qu'il faut travailler il
faut avoir un objectif derrière lui
bon ça cet objectif ils peuvent pousser
à aller de l'avant mais il ya plein de
gens qui voient qu'il ya en chacun de la
jeune fille mais aussi un chemin où il
ya rien
c'est un enfant je regardais vers l'est
pour moi je me suis rendu compte qu'ils
en fait en sorte que rares étaient tous
vous vous fourvoyez cette porte à porte
avec les motifs la réussite mais sur vos
deux mains mais aussi d'éthique des
faits qu'il faut bien sûr ce titre
quelque chose en fait si les faits ne
faut pas s'arrêter à la première ou à la
deuxième
moi c'est ce que j'ai fait est en fait
la paix j'ai passé les quelques années
elle travaille et je sais ça faisait ça
et tout mais je me suis dit un jour
quand même tu apprends la safer de trois
ans migron de faire quelque chose j'en
avais marre c'est que mes parents et mon
premier voyage à trapani et même si
c'était pas grand chose à mes yeux c'est
était quand même en je pensais que m
c'était un progrès
hier soir un philosophe piétine le
progrès même si l'appétit
il reste un travail et ça pour voir
c'était une paire est de la somalie
il fallait jamais arrêté j'ai passé des
années à travailler mais a pris un jour
mon père m'avait dit yang
s'ils font un petit chariot type comme
ça mais moi je conserve mon papa je
possède ce type il est déjà tard j'ai
passé les deux fois plus avoir à être
spécial médias et j'ai fait à moi j'ai
rien je pense que je vais préférer verra
et puis il reste jusqu'à la fin de la
durée d'exposition
ça veut dire que les autres rues plus
que de besoin pour travailler et moi ma
manière et m'a dit tu veux faire la
russie voulait dans une sphère le faire
je sais quoi qu'est ce qui peut être
fait sur la tête je le voulais et puis
je me suis dit tiens il reste une
semaine pour bien faire ces cellules et
l'a1 pour bien la quatrième je ne rentre
pas à protéger ces deux appartiennent
malgré toutes les difficultés si vous
êtes plus élevé d'être un prix garder ça
se fait là il faisait travailler et je
ne devais pas abandonner alors je
travaillerai les bixi tout au long de
cette semaine j'y croyais à jeun disait
que c'est juste pour leur dire que ça y
est je les fais les quatre ans qui
viennent
mes enfants je les connais les peser et
nostalgie n'était posée en une semaine
je me suis dit tiens ta faire un tour à
déposer sans merci toujours n'était pas
complètement pierre je n'étais pas
complètement certains à constater une
chose qui va pas céder
mais j'ai complètement campion l'un de
mes objectifs c'était de la déposer et
ça commence était une petite fierté
ainsi que le début bon et fils thomas
mais j'ai passé deux mois
oubliez vous considérez que ça lui fait
penser qu'ils allaient accepter à ses
devoirs journée mais là il y avait un
jour j'étais c'était des vacances du roi
monde à bâtir tard j'ai de l'espoir
vous lui disiez ça va être cool et puis
j'ai vu ma moto mais vous avez été
invité et vous avez été sélectionné une
petite porte qui ressort c'est pas sûr
il s'agite et je me rendais pas compte
vous voyez que c'était une erreur qui
lui disaient si tu clak saison de rigolo
au fond de moi je suis un fils
c'est une des raisons qui les avait deux
semaines ou deux mois tandis que et ça
pour moi c'était une compte fierté et
n'était qu'un début le début je vais
devoir rentrer bien te plaît
et puis j'ai reçus conclût jdd mais cet
appui j'ai quelque sorte un cadeau gay
et bolt avec notre comptable de ces
camions parce qu'on a prise de
d'étouffer cette flamme qui est pop qui
fait marcher ses photos mais aussi je me
suis senti que je répare et là quand
vous travaillez vous travaillez votre
avez vous travaillé à un moment donné il
va falloir prendre boiseau parce qu'il
suffisait de fatick et si vous en avez
marre là ça ne continue à travailler
votre effectif sera pas rentable mais si
vous prenez juste une pause de deux ou
trois jours on se rêvait nouvelle
personne comme si vous êtes vous quand
il voulait brûler moi j'ai très
improbable tout à l'heure je vous
parlais de ré avec des réalisateurs
en fait moi j'ai reçu j'ai encore pas
réaliser mon rêve c'est du moins la
version diesel et vous savez moi je vais
la jouer maintenant
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]